Here's another example of
a computational problem, multiplication of integers.
Similar to addition, we can ask what the cost
of this computation is.
If we consider the standard
multiplication algorithm, meaning the base two analog of the method for multiplying numbers
taught in elementary schools,
which is basically just
shifting and adding when we're working with numbers in binary, we find that there are Boolean circuits having size big-O of N squared
for multiplying N-bit integers.
I won't go through this one in detail. Of course the circuits are a
little bit more complicated than the ones for addition, but if you think about the way
that the standard
multiplication algorithm works, it shouldn't come as a surprise.
In essence, we need to
do roughly N additions, each of which has linear cost, and so we end up with
quadratic cost overall.
This can be generalized. If one of the numbers has N bits and the other one has N bits, then we need circuits of
size big-O of N times M.
Here, by the way, we are actually using an extension of the big-O notation where we have multiple variables, but it can be extended like this,
and if you're interested
in the specific details, I'll refer you to the textbook
content for the lesson, which again is linked in
the video description.
It's actually possible
to multiply together two N-bit integers in a way
that's asymptotically superior to the standard multiplication algorithm.
In particular, the Schonhage-Strassen multiplication algorithm
multiplies two N-bit integers with a cost of big-O of
N times the length of N
times the length of the length of N. So as N gets large, like
tens of thousands of bits,
this is actually a more
efficient way to multiply, but it's complicated and the overhead does make it impractical
for smaller numbers.
So let's add multiplication
to our list of examples.
And just for simplicity, let's list the cost given by the standard multiplication algorithm, which is big-O of N squared.
So once again, we're focusing on the essential nature of this cost, which is that it scales quadratically
or sub quadratically if we use asymptotically superior methods.
We can also consider the
problem of integer division, which is stated precisely on the screen.
Here we're talking about computing a quotient and a remainder, so the answer consists
of two integers, Q and R.
Once again, there's a standard
algorithm for division and it also has quadratic
cost and like multiplication,
there are in fact asymptotically
superior algorithms.
So how do GCD algorithms compare?
Well, Euclid's algorithm turns
out to have quadratic cost, and that's what I meant
earlier in the lesson when I said that we can compute GCDs
at roughly the same cost as multiplying two numbers together.
Once again, there are
asymptotically superior algorithms along similar lines to
addition and multiplication,
although the cost is a little
bit higher in this case, as least as far as we know.
I'll mention just one more example of a problem to add to this list, and that's modular exponentiation.
Here there are three input
numbers, K, M, and N, and the goal is to compute
N to the power K modulo-M,
which means the remainder
after we divide by M.
It's not at all obvious, but we can compute modular
exponentiation at qubit cost, meaning big-O of N cubed
for N-bit integers.
The way to do this one is not to first compute N to the power K and then compute the remainder.
Even writing down into the power K could require exponentially many bits, so that approach won't work.
Instead, we can use an algorithm
called the power algorithm, which is also called repeated squaring where everything is done modulo-M
and we use the bits of
K to iteratively square and multiply in a way
that makes it all work.
So this one is more
expensive than the others, but we can still perform
modular exponentiation quite quickly on numbers
with many thousands of bits.
So how do the costs of these tasks compare with integer factorization?
If we start simple and
think about trial division where we first check to see if two is a factor of the input number
and then check three and so on, we'll end up with a pretty
expensive algorithm, big-O of N squared times
two to the power N over two.
Each division takes quadratic time and in the worst case, we'll need to search for prime factors up to the square root of the input number,
and that's where the N
over two is coming from. If we haven't found a
prime factor at that point, we can just stop because then
the input number itself must be prime.
This is extremely expensive because N appears as an exponent in this expression, which is to say that this
algorithm has exponential cost.
In contrast, all of the examples that we have in this box here have what we call polynomial cost where N gets raised to a power,
but that power is always a fixed number that doesn't grow as
the input length grows.
In these cases, the powers
are one, two, and three.
I'll come back to polynomial versus exponential cost in just a moment, but first, let's finish off
what we know about factoring.